hey good folks John dallona here I'm new
to Ramsey solutions team I've been here
for a few months they call me dr. D
around here
so great to be here be with you for the
better part of two decades I've worked
as a senior leader at universities and
colleges working with students and their
families and the local communities in
crisis response and Victim Services care
I care deeply about people being well
people have its solid relational IQs
right being good relationships with
themselves with their loved ones with
their communities and for helping people
reclaim their lives from the fear and
the anxiety and the noise of this crazy
time I have an incredible wife and I
have two incredible extraordinary little
kids I'm living through this madness
just like you you may be asking yourself
why in the world that Dave Ramsey to get
out a dead guy hire a mental health dude
to join his team Dave and his team have
always said that when we have problems
dealing with our money it's often a sign
of bigger or deeper challenges in our
hearts and in our minds and in our
relationships I'm here to help us help
you with those bigger challenges I have
a PhD in higher education I have another
PhD in counseling I don't have a lot of
friends but I read a lot of stupid books
right but I've both did is study this
stuff and more importantly have lived
through it walking with countless folks
through their own challenges into their
victories and I've been lay below by my
own mental health challenges and my own
stupid decisions and I know firsthand
that there is a light at the end of the
tunnel I'm joining you here as a fellow
traveler as someone who has seen a lot
and done a lot of dumb stuff and that
brings me to today we've got this global
health pandemic right we've got
unimaginable economic consequences a
highly contagious infection of fear and
a fourth under discussed crisis that I'm
calling this the great disconnection and
in the great disconnection the best
thing we can do for our friends and our
families and neighbors is to stay away
we're acknowledging that these are scary
times but there are things we can do
right now to address the uncertainty and
a gain perspective and traction of what
tomorrow may look like so I want to
start with this I recently heard Bernie
Browns say this is everybody's first
pandemic so let's all be a little more
graceful with one another right and
I love that this is my first pandemic
this is your first pandemic so let's all
just to exhale and lean into the fact
that we are doing the best that we can
right so the first is the great
disconnection I'm an introvert who was
born and raised in Texas we raised the
cows that gave the leather for the boot
straps that we're all supposed to have
pulled ourselves up by the idea that we
can live alone and do life alone is a
myth it's a lie we need other people and
it pains me to say that but we do some
of us are also suddenly homeschooling
kids and for those of you who are single
you found yourself in your one-bedroom
apartment in a wall in a wall and a wall
suddenly feels more like a prison and
less like a home and some of you are
totally alone and make no mistake we can
all find ourselves alone in a crowded
room right just because I'm bumping
shoulders with my wife or running into
my kids doesn't mean I don't feel lonely
inside I've had several close friends
experiences sudden loss of parents
recently and they were not able to hold
their full funerals or hug their family
members this thing is robbing us of our
humanity of the things that make us who
we are and that's our relationships Oh
overnight we got disconnected and that
brings me to the second major thing I
want to talk about I want to talk
through what's happening in our brains
in our bodies and we're labeling
everything as fear and anxiety fear and
anxiety and I think it's much more
nuanced than that here's the deal
anxiety is just a fire alarm it's an
alarm that sense is something in your
environment is out of whack and you may
not be safe anxiety is just a fire alarm
and achoo anxiety disorder all that
means is the alarm is broken it's going
off it's strange in our unfortunate
times and it's been going on for a while
now we've all been in somebody's kitchen
and they have a very sensitive smoke
alarm that keeps going off or every time
we open the door to pull out some
cookies or a pizza or something right or
we've all been in buildings when they're
testing the fire alarms and they just
keep going off and off and they say keep
working and but you can't email you
can't talk on the phone you can't hold a
conversation and you're just finding
yourself you just find yourself wanting
to run out of the building these
feelings of anxiety and fear are real
they are way more under our control than
we think they are and additionally what
we label as anxiety and fear is often
just a wrong label I want us to reclaim
some of our vocabulary right as a
culture we've often lost any sort of
vocabulary beyond anxiety depression and
fear and we've made wrong any sort of
emotion that doesn't make us feel happy
or anything that doesn't make us feel
comfortable I can't tell you how many
times I've told people dude your parents
just got divorced you're not depressed
you're sad and you're supposed to be sad
right or you just sent an email on
Friday you shouldn't have sent it and
you may be unemployed on Monday
that's not anxiety that's called guilt
and regret and so I want to help us
expand our vocabulary and want us to be
so much more graceful with ourselves and
with those in our community some of you
may be feeling exposed or guilt for not
having planned better with your money
and now you've got so much credit card
debt and then BAM out of the blue Murphy
shows up at an axe is law some of us
feel ashamed that we're annoyed or
frustrated by our kids are running
around or that we don't love
homeschooling we don't love working
side-by-side with our spouse right
because good moms and dads don't don't
not love having the kids running around
everywhere right or good husbands and
wives don't love you next to each other
all the time you may be feeling lonely
it may be becoming clear that when the
noise and the dust of your business
settles you're looking around and
realizing you are totally alone or maybe
you're just right angry at your
government and grits your kids angry at
the cosmos angry angry there's no prom
no graduations no third dates it's all
postponed and weddings may be angry many
of us have been so busy go go go go go
for the past few years that we haven't
honestly felt your emotions in a long
time we run from the gym to breakfast to
work to children's activities to church
the television to bed and repeat some of
us are so exhausted and spun out and
disconnected that in addition to the
fear we're feeling we're also feeling
our addiction to the rush and speed of
everything just going away
there's so much going on in our hearts
and in our heads there's so much going
on between people and all these feelings
are normal and they're too
expected and all of us are experiencing
them so be kind to yourself and other
people and be slow to label everything
anxiety or fear and just know your
feelings are normal and you're just
feeling the full range of being a person
but regardless of what we call it we're
being flooded by emotions and our
fight-or-flight has been fully engaged
and we're wondering what to do and that
leads us to the final feeling that I
believe is the most painful especially
for a culture like ours it believes we
have the answer to everything and that's
this dreadful feeling of uncertainty the
world feels like it is unfolding in
front of us right like watching the
tsunami coming right at us
maybe right we don't even know and in
some ways we're feeling paralyzed scared
some of us have put certainty in our
jobs and our marriages bank accounts and
our bodies clearly I have put it in my
body right but we've put our certainty
in our kids position on the little
league team and our tinder profile our
political affiliations and our status or
whatever and it too is suddenly gone and
these feelings of uncertainty can feel
unsettling and unnerving when the
foundation that we've been anchored to
for so long is well ripped away and that
brings us to the third thing living in
real time through a transforming world
we are all experiencing uncertainty as
we live through a transforming moment
history and there's no question about it
things will look different after this
and we know this and there's nothing we
can do about it we're having an
extraordinary wake-up call for the lives
that we all took for granted and so I
want to provide you some tips for what
you can do right now to get reconnected
to absorb and feel your emotions and
live in it and start making plans for
what's coming next so what are we gonna
do right what are we gonna do as I said
earlier I've spent many years responding
to the worst crisis imaginable I've
trained with SWAT teams and police
forces I've been behind closed doors
during some hard university
conversations and I found myself
planning for some really crazy
situations and I always jump into
challenges with two basic principles
number one I can only control my
thoughts in my actions period number two
I've always want to believe this will
probably get better but it might get
worse and I want to hold both of these
in tension choosing to focus on the
optimal side right things are gonna get
better but holding space and having a
plan for what might happen if it doesn't
and since anxiety and fear turns off my
critical thinking skills I want to do
everything in my power as far upstream
as possible to have my character who I'm
gonna be during this time edged into
stone and so with these two principles
in mind here are some concrete steps for
dealing with the great disconnection
with the flood of emotions including
fear and anxiety and - how to deal with
the uncertainty of watching history
unfold underneath our feet number one
recognize that which you can control and
let go of everything else everything as
I said earlier you can only control two
things on planet earth your thoughts and
your behavior period the faster you can
take ownership of what you can control
and the other things you can't control
the better off you will be you can
control how much nonsense on the
internet you fill your mind with you can
control how much time you spend on
social media you can control how much
you dwell on the what-ifs and the
doomsday scenarios and you can control
how you are to your wife and to your
kids and to your husband's in to your
neighbors you can control how much grace
you give to your coworker you can
control if you just get up and go mow
your neighbor's yard just just for
something to do right you control your
thoughts and your actions and this may
be a great moment for looking for other
small things you can control - like
cleaning out your garage or your claws
that are learning to meditate from one
of the 8 million apps reading that stack
of books you've been trying to get to
and you just never have or exercising
intermittent fasting or whatever goofy
things are saying that we're supposed to
all be doing in these days right but you
can take control of small bits of your
day but take this unprecedented moment
in history to exhale and begin to regain
more control over the things in your
life which you previously let go of
number two make a plan make a plan every
day at Ramsey we say make a new budget
every month while we're in New Times
ladies and gentlemen so we're gonna make
a new plan every day it takes like 10
minutes spin
in minutes with your spouse with your
roommate invites your kids if you can
and just make sure everyone's on the
same page
our brains trick us into believing that
familiar is safe and it's why people
stay in abusive relationships or they
keep working in places where their boss
is a tyrant or awful because familiar
feels safe and now for many of us
nothing's familiar anymore right it's
all frustrating we weren't trained to be
home school teachers we certainly
weren't trained to be stay-at-home
employees next to our significant other
all day long we weren't trained to be
computer programmers are locked in our
apartments by ourselves right so our
brains are sounding every alarm that we
have right so in addition to the plan
having a daily routine is critical here
right for the last week people have been
asking me what's your what's your daily
routine what's your daily routine here
it is I just brought it for you k every
morning I wake up with this same plan
super high-tech this is it this is my
daily routine every day the night before
I go to bed I get this fancy device
called a index card for some of the
young folks it's an index card and I
write on it with this cool gadget called
a pen right and I just write down what's
gonna happen tomorrow half of its with
work and half of its with private and
personal stuff today was wake up early
go for a long walk
work out my gratitude journal which I've
got right here my regular journal and
here's a scripture journal that me and
my dad and my brothers share every
morning hugs with family prayer time I
have to write an article today I've got
to do a bunch of recording and stuff
today and try not to do sugar and grains
today cuz I gotta get control of my head
back and we're gonna watch our church
service that we skipped yesterday all
that to say is and then we're gonna get
home and I'm gonna play with the kids
it's gonna be a fun night but it's
tracking your day and I just mark it off
old-school lo-fi everybody it's awesome
right so number three research out of
Rice University and really all across
the world shows that stress loneliness
and lack of sleep can make you more
susceptible to the Cova 19 virus again
going back to the things youth in
control managing stress loneliness and
sleep is critical so how do we do that
be very very selective about where you
get your information
the four basic news channels and rogue
internet providers that's not where it's
coming from their job is not to give you
science and their job is not to give you
correct information their job is to get
clicks call people who know like your
doctor or call or listen to people that
you trust period okay
limit the places that you get advice
from nature and sunshine and bird
chirping and all that it's critical to
your mental health and to your physical
health go outside multiple times every
day my buddy Kevin and Michael they live
in Texas and they sent me a note the
other day they just said they went out
walking and it looked like the federal
government had mandated that everyone
get out of their homes because
everyone's out walking their dogs and
their neighborhoods and waving to people
me and my family were going on multiple
walks a day sometimes alone sometimes
with all of us I make a point to wave to
everyone to say hello and just be kind
my kids have picked up on it well I'm
doing it to spread joy to my
neighborhood I know I'm receiving joy
back as well and you've heard all of my
friends here at Ramsey say this but I'm
gonna say it again
protect your four walls your family is
not cared for if you just lost your job
finding out exactly what they need we'll
give you a path to get you peace get out
of your head and write it down if that
means heading out to local grocery store
to stock groceries get on it it's no
pride we're not time for that
I don't care where went to school how
smart you are be a hero for your family
and get scrappy and start doing the
things you need to do to put food on the
table also eat right exercise and sleep
I tell you what dude I've eaten so bad
in the last week I'm making my
commitment right here on on this
national streaming device I'm gonna
start doing better my family does ours
better my work community deserves better
you deserve better okay and then making
sure you sleep next is Connect connect
connect our devices aren't the best
right but they're what we have right now
FaceTime with your mom
hug your family talk with your wife if
you've got friends who are who are
medical workers and they're stuck
calling every day FaceTime them if you
can those people are lonely and they are
doing hero's work every day right
FaceTime with a new friend every single
day I got to catch up with old college
roommates that I haven't talked to in
years it's been incredible and protect
your relationships how do you do that
number one be kind do
and I talked about the other day on the
Dave Ramsey show we're gonna start a
kindness revolution right where we're
gonna go first we're gonna reach out and
just be kind remember that your kids
your employees your neighbors everyone's
watching you model good behavior model
kindness especially moms and dads here
be vulnerable admit to loved ones that
you're scared admit to loved ones that
you're frightened you don't know what to
do men your wife and your kids will love
you for looking them in the eye taking
their hands and saying I'm kind of
scared cuz I don't know what to do they
can all feel it on your right that
you're nervous that you're scared you're
trying to be tough just be honest
you'll find yourself on the back end of
this deal closer than you ever imagined
you've got to be emotionally dependable
because you are the adult moms and dads
you are the adults and that doesn't mean
acting like you know everything or
spilling your conspiracy theories on to
kids and your small groups at church and
all the neighbors there it means being
still making and holding boundaries now
giving in to rage or being a jerk being
open and honest with your family and
being present put your phones down as we
talked about this before this is
bringing up all sorts of emotions in all
of us right but you may have had hidden
for years and years every mental health
provider that I know has moved their
practice online so if you find yourself
overwhelmed with emotions or fear
contact somebody immediately reach out
to leaders at your local church but
don't just sit in isolation and finally
look for places to serve your community
and your family find places to serve
gets a kid out of your own head right
quits thinking about what's coming and
go do this could be writing letters this
could be checking on people in your
church checking with folks before you
need to go to the store to see if they
need anything it's gonna be picking up
trash in your neighborhood with your
kids on your walks right or buying local
and tipping like mad where possible and
keep sending memes dude I tell you what
I've seen some of the funniest memes
ever flying around over the past few
weeks and they're bringing joy to my
sarcastic little heart right
and speaking of service here at Ramsey
solutions I've only been here a few
months and I tell you what behind the
curtain it's incredible the first thing
that went down last week they thought
how can we serve this
how can we serve his community and they
got in a room and started hammering
things out they scoured their products
for tools and resources that we can give
away or make the prices so low that
basically we're giving them away to help
folks through these wild and uncertain
times you may have heard this it is ba
na na s dude but for the first time ever
we're offering a free 14 day trial of
Financial Peace University and every
dollar budgeting app Financial Peace
University has helped millions of people
get control of their money but more
importantly it's get control of
themselves of their hearts of their
relationships although why they do the
things they do go to Dave Ramsey comm /
hope and start your free trial and while
you're there we're selling ebooks we're
giving stuff away it's our way of saying
hey make it happen while you're stuck at
home make it happen right we want to
serve you I don't to leave you with this
from one of my mentors Randy Harris he
often said that sarcasm and pessimism so
often present themselves as wisdom and
joy and optimism so often look dumb or
uninformed we get to choose one or the
other but I'm asking each of you to work
towards joy to lean in and work towards
optimism may you laugh often be of much
joy and may we all be a little more kind
we're in this together I'm here with you
we'll talk to you soon this is John
Delon